hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even
more
how are you guys doing it's been a long
time hasn't it it's been a long time
since you've heard the champ since
you've been acquainted with the champ
since you've had the privilege of
hearing the Champ's voice how are you
guys doing long time it has been I came
across a video and this video was um
actually interesting because it reminded
me of another video and might be this is
kind of confusing now but let me tell
you what I'm talking about reminds me of
another video so this is Joe Rogan and
he says something which is very common
sensical but which we think we have the
answer for let's listen to what he has
to say you know I was having a
conversation with a friend of mine about
this yesterday we were talking about how
complex the human mind is and how
complex life and Society is but yet
there's no real management book
like there's no real there's no document
that shows you this is the optimal way
to exist and these are the pitfalls of
existing other ways that you know you
have these human reward systems built in
and they can be hijacked by these
various things and this is the way the
human body and the human
mind exist optimally now this reminded
me guys this reminded me of the
legendary and the famous and the
prolific drct Zak Nike and one of his
very famous lines that he used to give
in front of the millions of people in
India and in other parts of the world
where he used to um give his public
lectures let's take a look at Zach
Nike's response to Joe Rogan whenever we
purchase an equipment along with the
equipment we get an instruction manual
for example when we purchase a DVD
player we get instruction manual which
tells us how the DVD player should be
operated if you want to play the DVD put
the disc and press the play button if
you want to skip press the skip button
if you want to stop press the stop
button don't drop it from a height it
will get damaged don't imerge water it
will get spoiled all these details are
given in the instruction manual whenever
you buy an equipment it has instruction
manual and more complicated the machine
the more requirement of the instruction
manual if you allow me to call the human
beings the machine I would say it is the
most complicated machine on the face of
this Earth don't you think it requires
an instruction manual the instruction
manual for the human beings it is the
Glorious Quran now you heard that guys
the thing is I totally agree with Zak
and Nike and I think all Muslims would
do because the thing is look if you
think about the human being as a
sentient conscientious being right and
if you agree that human being has Free
Will and the ability to make a decision
right and wrong and that the human
being um is different actually is
fundamentally differentiated from all
other life forms is fundamentally
differentiated from animals from from
plants from bacteria and so on and so
forth the question is what is the
purpose of life for the human being and
the quranic answer to that or the
Islamic answer to that is that the human
being is made to worship God but putting
it another way the human being has to be
one with nature and the way to be one
with nature to put it in that sense is
to do what everything else in nature is
doing and everything else in nature is
submitting its will to its creator to
the sustainer of the universe to the
creator of the heavens and the Earth
Allah subhanahu wa tala and so the
differentiating factor between human
being and everything else in creation is
that human being really has a choice to
do what everything else in creation is
doing to fundamentally obey the Creator
and yes that choice is made through the
instruction
manual that the Creator through his love
and mercy and wisdom has given the human
being in order to follow we believe in
the previous dispensations we believe in
the the books of old the tat and the
injil the gospels and the tah but we
believe that the final dispensation that
was sent to human beings is the one that
was sent to Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam the prophet Muhammad s.
wasallam and I think every human being
owes it to themsel
to investigate at least this book and to
see if the instruction manual would in
fact be the one that would lead to the
ultimate guidance as the Quran
states that say bring a book that is
more in guidance than the Quran and the
Torah and I will follow it if you are
truthful so let's take a look at the
Quran and take a look at all the other
books that claim to be from God and that
offer the ultimate guidance and see
which one you think is the one that
would lead to the ultimate guidance in
this world and in the Hereafter you owe
it to yourself as a human being to do at
least
that the prophet Muhammad s. wasam told
us whoever builds a mosque for Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in Jenna and we know the great reward
that will not only be gained but rather
will fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your
scale